We just got a bunch of Donald Trump's tax
filings and they're stunning and um, these
are not look full.
I think before we go any further, I should
remind you these are not the tax returns.
These are not like the much coveted recent
personal tax returns that Congress is trying
to get from the treasury.
These are filings from 1985 to 1994, uh, for
Donald Trump.
But what they reveal is absolutely fascinating.
You'll remember that Donald Trump ran on being
a great business person and a dealmaker.
And in fact, if you take that away, if you
question Donald trumps credentials as a great
business person and a deal maker, the guy
has no credentials of any kind.
It's sort of scary whether being a good deal
maker makes you a good president is a, is
an open question.
But if you take that pseudo credential away,
there's nothing there at all.
But then you might remember that during the
2016 campaign, people started rightly bringing
up, wait, wait a second, hold on.
Your businesses have filed for bankruptcy
many times.
Are you actually the great businessperson
you claim to be?
And Trump's explanation at the time was that's
because I was using bankruptcy as a strategic
tool to my advantage.
It wasn't because my businesses were failing
businesses.
It wasn't that I made bad deals when my business
is declared bankruptcy.
I was intelligently taking advantage of bankruptcy
protection.
There is a fantastic new report in the New
York Times, which tells us that that's very,
very much untrue.
It looked at Donald Trump's 10 40, which is
the, the uh, primary federal tax form from
1985 to 1994.
And it is painting a very different picture
of Trump than genius businessman, which is
what he has touting for years now over the
10 year period that the New York Times reviewed,
Donald Trump reported 1.1 $7 billion in losses.
This was not common with high net worth tax
payers at the time who would be taking strategic
losses for a, in order to gain tax advantages.
Trump's losses were outliers at the time.
They were extraordinarily big and they were
genuine business losses.
These were not strategic right downs or write
offs or a use of sophisticated accounting
measures.
And in fact, you know how Trump said that
finding ways to avoid paying taxes would make
him smart.
There was nothing smart about this.
Trump avoided federal income taxes for eight
of the 10 years that were reviewed, not because
of trickier sophisticated accounting maneuvers.
He straight up lost a ton of money and therefore
avoided paying taxes during eight of the 10
years that the New York Times reviewed.
And more importantly, Donald Trump's staff
have been continuing to tell massive and demonstrably
false lies about all of this.
The New York Times was working on the story.
Uh, so they went to Donald Trump's team to
get a comment about what they had uncovered
and a senior official said to them, quote,
the president got massive depreciation and
tax shelter because of large scale construction.
And subsidized developments.
That is why the president has always scoffed
at the tax system and said, you need to change
the tax laws.
You can make a large income and not have to
pay large amount of taxes.
This is just not true.
Okay?
This again makes it sound like tax sheltering
and subsidies and depreciation losses created
on paper losses for Trump, which allowed him
to really intelligently avoid taxes during
eight of those 10 years.
Those are flat out lies.
And in fact, a lawyer for Donald Trump put
out a statement saying that what the New York
Times is claiming about Trump is demonstrably
false.
But when that lawyer was asked, well, what's
an example of something that's demonstrably
false?
If it's demonstrably false, demonstrate that
it's false.
And Trump's lawyer was unable to actually
cite a single specific claim that is demonstrably
false.
So what we've learned here, um, is that Donald
Trump's tax avoidance during these specific
years was not this enlightened proactive tax
strategy.
It was indicative of an unstable and poorly
run business that was losing actual money
period.
Now with Trump, there's always usually lurking
in the background, a dose of hypocrisy that
we can often find if we look at his tweets
and in fact Trump tweeted in 2012 that quote,
half of Americans don't pay income tax despite
crippling government debt as if they're bad
people.
Well, Trump was one of those people for eight
of the 10 years that the New York Times reviewed
in the mid eighties and the mid nineties and
if we ever actually got Donald Trump's more
recent tax returns, my guess is we would find
out that he was also one of those people not
paying federal taxes at the same time that
he sent the tweet criticizing that quote,
nearly half of Americans don't pay income
tax this morning.
Trump clearly rattled by this, put out a tweet,
a actually a to tweet word salad, which read
quote real estate developers in the 1980s
and nineties and nineties more than 30 years
ago.
We're entitled to massive write offs and depreciation,
which would, if one was actively building
show losses and tax losses in almost all cases
much was nonmonetary sometimes considered
tax shelter.
You would get it by building or even buying.
You always wanted to show losses for tax purposes.
Almost all real estate developers did and
often renegotiate with banks.
It was sport.
Additionally, the very old information put
out is a highly inaccurate fake news hit job.
Almost everything he said in there was not
true.
Um, the sort of common nature of what was
revealed in Trump's tax filings is not actually
common.
Uh, the idea that Donald Trump's losses were
only on paper losses for the reasons he sighting
is not true.
I mean, none of this is true.
It's certainly not fake news.
And it's actually been confirmed by looking
at the tax filings of his dad, Fred Trump
at the time.
They were involved in a lot of the same projects
financially and everything absolutely matches
up.
So why do we care about this?
We care about this because number one, Trump
has gone crazy to prevent his more recent
tax returns from being released.
And now we have proof that Trump has lied
about his tax history.
He lies and his advisers lie about the characterization
of why he shows losses.
Um, uh, on many years.
And we know that it's very, very likely on
this basis that Donald Trump is just not nearly
as rich as he has claimed to be.
He's an EGOMANIAC that would upset him if
it were confirmed, but maybe more importantly,
people this far in the red, people who were
losing this much money are, uh, uh, uh, subject
to, are easier to manipulate and to take advantage
of, which is exactly what many of the investigations
into Trump or looking at Russian oligarchs
laundering money through Trump's businesses
over the more recent years, the problems with
sketchy Deutscha bank dealings, Saudis using
Trump's properties to launder money.
Uh, later on today I'm going to tell you about
a connection to the second in command and
Nicolas Maduro regime involved in real estate
purchases from Trump organization businesses.
And lastly, if you look into the detail of
this investigation, you can pick almost any
number that is in the tax filings and investigate
it.
And you might find some sin, something sketchy.
Like for example, in [inaudible] 89, there
was a $52 million interest payment.
W what is that?
That number alone might have an entire history
behind it, which could be anything.
It could be nothing or it could be more sketchy
and strange.
We need Trump's more recent tax returns.
Hopefully Democrats in the house can get them
sooner than later so that we can actually
learn the full scope of this.
Um, and most Americans want to see those tax
returns.
Every other candidate in the last 40 years,
uh, has released their tax returns.
We've got to see them and hopefully the house
ways and means committee will ultimately be
able to get them.
What do you think is the most notable thing
about Trump's 85 to 94 taxes?
I'm on Twitter, let me know at the pacman
and the show is also
on
Twitter at David Pakman show,